hello everyone and welcome to my first
video of 2018 I was gonna do this video
this game during the world rapper
championship but those games were simply
too rapid I couldn't manage the time
this is a game from round 10 and
although Joe Bob adore had had an
excellent first day I think he finished
in shirt first place with Vladimir
feather save his luck kind of ran out
throughout the tournament at this game
he's playing against chakra mum in the
Arab and it's it's quite a wild game
there's a brilliant tactic involved and
I will let you find it the the winning
move for ourselves so let's see this
game and of course I hope you all had a
had a very nice celebration of the new
year if you were celebrating it so
chapala here has the white pieces and he
plays d4 we have Knight to f6 and Bishop
to g5 the trump offski attack 924 Bishop
to f4 and now d5 f3 Knight back to d6
Knight to c3 and a 6
III Bishop to e7 Queen d2 Knight to d7
queenside castle by Java King side
castle by mama they are off and keep the
b1 we have c6 and Bishop to d3 and
already this is move 10 mamedyarov goes
for Sun King side expansion would be 5
planning ideas like before maybe a 4 a 5
and only then before and already you can
see that black already started his
attack on the Queen side and the Obama
still hasn't pushed either g4 h 4 or
whatever his plan is and here it he
definitely has to find a plan sure
pushing on the King side is definitely
what the white wants to do here but
maybe you know you're gonna be behind on
time as like I said my media already
started expanding on the Queen side and
here may be a principle move would be
something like e for your opponent
attacks on the Queen side maybe want to
break open the center but in this
position Jabba decided to play Bishop
captures on d6
Bishop captures on d6 and F for now and
this immediately allows mama dro to put
b4 and he does Knight c2e2 and c5 now D
captures on c5 Knight captures and
five and Knight to f3 you have to
develop your pieces as well and the a5
my mama dro and already you can see that
blacks pawns are very close a 4 is
coming B 3 is coming this will
completely bust open Weiss Kings
defenses we have night e to d4 and it's
it's a great square for the knight yo
baba is guarding e5 so know if I've can
ever come this night will be will be an
excellent piece here also it will be
able to help out with the defense we had
a 4 and now h4 Najibullah starts his own
expansion on the Kings side Bishop to a6
g4 we have Queen to b6 and King to a-1
and instead of this King to a1
the king is actually pretty safe and b1
there is really no reason to play King
to it 1 Kings day one was actually
losing move here black is definitely
better
white white might have simply continued
pushing age 5 and and try something
there Knight to e5 is an idea but King
to a-1 it was probably played with the
idea that the king the King doesn't stay
on the B file as the Queen is also
occupying the B file but King to a-1
actually loses the game immediately and
this is the position I wanted you to see
and find it the winning move I will give
it a couple of seconds for you to decide
whether we want to try and solve this
for ourselves so do try it okay for
those of you who managed to solve it
it's not that difficult it's it's
actually pretty simple but it's quite
impressive as it's a rapid game Bishop
captures on d3 and this wins the game
immediately you can capture with the
Queen tonight is protecting the bishop
you can't capture with the pawn but this
still loses the game there's really no
good move in this position in the game
see capture some d3 was played and now
comes the move Knight to b3 check as you
can see there's this again wonderful
relationship between the king queen and
this night tonight comes to be three
checks the King and forks the Queen so
you you have to capture the night or you
lose the Queen and I think it was in
this position that
just 24 posted disposition on Twitter
and said those who live by the source
sometimes die by the sword so I really
like that title that's why I used it and
you know who lives by the sword if not
the jalalabad or so what what do you do
here
the problem is you can't capture with
the a pawn and this is the idea I wanted
you to find it when I said pause the
position
pause the video sorry if you play a
captures night on b3 you get eight
Hector zombie 3 and this opens up a
discover check from the rock on a8 only
movie schemes to be won and now comes
the Punisher Rock to a-1 check there is
no move for the king at the pawn is
guarding the c2 square you have to
capture the rook King captures and out
comes Queen to a6 this is with Chuck
King to be won only move Queen to a to
check King to see one only moon and now
Queen to a1 and this is checkmate so
that's the problem after Knight to b3
you can't not capture the night and you
can't capture it with the point you have
to capture with the night that was
played in the game night capture some b3
we have a capture some b3 and 83 now be
captures on a3 keen to be one getting
the King away from the be far from the a
file and it never should have gotten
onto the a file and there are actually a
lot of winning winning moves here you
can simply bring the rook into the game
you can capture you can push a to really
there's nothing white can do to stop
this attack in the game on MIDI out of
play Bishop to b4 with a tempo on the
Queen Queen to e2 and now it captures
some b2 would the threat of well you
have to capture the pawn of course if
you capture with the Queen Queen the
King rook to a2 checks the King you lose
the Queen if you try something like
Knight the d4 to bring another piece
into the attack it doesn't really matter
rook to e1 check King characters now
rook to a2 you have to move the king now
you either lose the Queen but you don't
even have to capture Queen simply Bishop
to c3 and there is no defense against
rock to a-1 checkmate you could capture
it for example but then simply be
captures and wherever the King goes it's
still checkmate so after this a capture
some b2 queen capture sambito was played
now comes
rook to a - attacking the Queen Queen
capture some b3 rook to a3 now again
harassing the Queen
although rook to e1 check was still
leading to checkmate but I will let you
find that one for yourself if you're
interested so rook to a3 was played
Queen Toby - and now rook to b8 now
there's simply too much pressure on that
beef I'll rock to c1 we have Queen to a6
and now Rock to c7 was played and after
job I'll play this rook to c7 he also
resigned the game because the game is
over for example simply Queen captures
on d3 this is what check and the King
doesn't really have any moves if you
play Queen to c2 simply Bishop to d2
this opens up a discovered to check from
the rook on b8 you have to block this
and rook captures on b7 this is
checkmate but after this rook to c7 the
game was over and a wild game and uh a
very nice victory for a shocker mama D
ro I haven't checked the feed a world
rating list as of 1st of January I don't
know if mama D ro is still in the top 10
but I don't think he played any
classical games in this period so he
probably still is I will have to check
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it and always remember he who lives by
the sword often dies by the sword that
is the old saying and here we have it
with a nice chess example I would like
to thank McCauley Polito and the unknow
hell for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon